take a look at this one
you look like a Calvin Klein model might
be the worst thing to tell a woman in
2023 so here's Calvin Klein ads okay so
now we've shifted from the gender stuff
there's this other thing where they're
really pushing they want uh overweight
or fat or obese people to be seen and
everything I'm not against overweight or
fat people everyone should try to take
care of themselves accordingly I suppose
we could all lose a couple off the
midsection uh but why are they pushing
this I thought it would be interesting
if we contrasted that with old school
Calvin Klein you remember this this is
from when I was a kid this is probably
from what what year was that from
probably about 92 94 something around
there that's Mark Wahlberg and and Kate
Moss now you might say she's too thin
and you might say no guy can look like
him that's fine but which one should
advertising is about aspiring to
something right which should you aspire
to to look like right relatively fit
people even if she was a little thin or
should we all look like obese people
there's there's a problem there's a
problem here in society and guess what
it's not just that they want people to
dress up like animals with these furry
conventions now they want the dogs to be
gay too here's Pet Smart that's right
show your pride if your cat's not a
lesbian
why do so many lesbians have cats
we should be doing a show about that
that's an interesting that would be far
more interesting what you could have is
a therapist sitting at PetSmart sitting
there going oh I see you're in the cat
section tell me about your lesbianism
that would be interesting to me but just
putting cats and dogs in rainbow colored
things it's so nonsensical Clyde is
downstairs I have every reason to
believe that Clyde everything being
equal you know he's been they did
whatever they chopped his nuts off but I
think that Clyde if he had his nuts
would would be into girl dogs but either
way why would I be putting him in
[Music]